one of the great secrets in life
to becoming successful
whether it's in a business whether it's
working with someone or for someone or
in your personal life
and i learned this selling encyclopedias
door-to-door early twenties
is be prepared in life for a lot of
rejection because if you're prepared for
a lot of rejection it comes you don't
get turned off you don't get
disappointed like well i'm not going to
do this anymore no one thinks it's a
good idea
it's like i say selling encyclopedias
knocking a hundred dollars they slap him
in your face you must be just as
enthusiastic under number 101 as door
number one and that's what the real
secrets and growing up as kids in
downtown la we all knew that we didn't
have a lot we noticed a lot of things
going to turn you down at 7 trying to
sell a flower pot on the street most
people said no but it's only 50 cents no
no no
sooner a waitress an old restaurant said
only 50 cents that's really great she
bought it from us and we went built
another one